Margaret's with us in New Jersey hey
Margaret
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you sir thank you for taking my call so
I recently found out about your program
I'm currently on babysit number two I am
in 173 thousand dollars worth of debt my
annual salary is 147 thousand but I'm
going to start the spell ball so I know
to do that but I am going through a
divorce and I'm about to move so I have
two questions for you my first question
is do I stop and like stack up my cash
yes or do i okay okay until you get the
two until you get through this
transition because the transitions
require cash right right and so the
house and house is going to be sold and
how much debt is that going to leave you
with I can't let me sell the house
because it's not just mine but I nothing
I'm not I'm not gonna be able to sell
the house because I'm with I have a
house I own a house with a business
partner not with my about to be
ex-husband so that's like kind of off
the table what I need to do is get
another job and I can do that be easily
I'm I applied for 3d jobs just last
night so hopefully that one of those
will come through so that's my plan yes
I live in the house I do know I'm
renting currently so who lives in the
house so the house is with a business
partner of mine that my ex-husband he's
actually lived in another country and so
the house is like totally not even
involved in the divorce that's a rental
yeah okay yeah so and it's not just mine
it's like a business like an upstart
home so I start at home so it was like a
business deal that we did back in 2010
and that's not on the table to be sold
so my only option I think is to get
another job how much debt do you have
there not counting that house 173,000
I mean consumer debt meaning like credit
cards and personal loans I mean my
school loan is only what 39k what do you
owe when you're calling a car
what do you owe on your car eleven
thousand and I plan to pay that off by
October because I have a balloon loan on
that and what again is your income today
147 147 okay your children at home I
have a yes and she's in private school
and I'm taking her out this year okay so
you're just going on beans and rice and
going to plough through the hundred and
seventy three thousand right after I can
get through the move and the divorce
well the I disagree with you that the
house with the business partner is not
on the table everything's on the table
you're choosing to not put on the table
and I might choose to put it on the
table the reason you bought it and 2010
was to make money on it and I suspect
it's got some equity in it that would
help you right now and so I'm gonna
challenge this assumption that it can't
be sold you bought it - you didn't fight
to keep the rest of your life you bought
it - sell it sell it I'm sorry and it's
not paid for my partner doesn't want to
sell it yeah well so you can buy you out
I don't think she's in a position to do
that right now
what's the terms of the partnership
agreement we in perpetuation yeah I have
I would have to look at the agreement I
mean that was so long ago but it brings
me in a little bit additional income I
gave about $900 a month from it no okay
well I mean so you think you're going to
be out of the hundred and seventy three
in what period of time that's making
three to four years okay now you're
getting after it well I do it yeah I
mean there's no question this is what
you need to do but you're right for
today I would not pile up I would not
attack the debt I would just pile up
some cash and get ready for the
transition
make sure your housing is settled your
income
settled your and then you you know once
the smoke clears the dust settles from
going through this divorce and you know
exactly what you're facing and you know
exactly what you've got coming in then
you just look at your plan and you step
on the gas and go but for today I would
just pile up cash and whatever pile of
cash you've got you can throw at the
debt so it's not like you're gonna lose
it we're not saying suggesting you spin
that Polly cash we're saying pile it up
if you don't use it in the transition or
going through the whole process that
you're going through then throw it at
the debt and take off and go